apple-cider is also known as sweet cider
or soft cider it's darker and cloudier
than conventional apple juice because
tiny bits of apple are not filtered out
these flavorful fragments are what makes
this fall beverage unique when the
apples on the trays are right it's time
to produce apple cider they process the
apples within days of the harvest to
produce a beverage that tastes both
fresh and sweet it starts with the right
mix of apples some varieties are sweet
and others are tart this mix of flavors
will spice things up the apples float to
the surface of a water filled pit and
drift onto a conveyor that takes them
into the cider mill
inside the mill the apple spill into a
washing station water sprays the apples
as they bounce across rolling brushes
[Music]
next the apples take a trip up to a
grinder inside a steel arm pushes the
apples against a grater it shreds them
pits and all into a pulp this pulp is
known as pumice the pumice lands in a
funnel from here a pump moves it through
pipes across the plant where it arrives
at a press the Apple pomace flows
between two porous belts that wind
around rollers the rollers apply
pressure to squeeze out the juice the
juice drips through holes in the belts
the process strains out most of the ball
but some remains as the juice spills
from the press into large catch pants
[Music]
then they pump this chunk the Apple
liquid into a holding tank
from the tank it flows through a
revolving drum that filters out more
pulp pits and Apple stems
the fluid seeps through the perforations
in the drum and flows into a large
trough
after one more screening only fine bits
of Apple and sentiment remain this gives
it the desired cider consistency and
flavor the cider now flows into channels
between hot steel plates the heat
destroys pathogens and bacteria that
would convert the natural sugars to
alcohol this ensures that the cider is
both safe to drink and non-alcoholic
it's now ready for bottling a worker
slides plastic jugs into position under
nozzles the nozzles descend and pump the
boiling hot apple cider into the jugs
they're filled to the brim so air can't
get inside air causes the cider to
deteriorate next the conveyor moves the
jugs forward to a capping station
plastic caps funnel toward the jugs as
they approach the caps land on the rims
with perfect timing spinning wheels
tighten the caps as the jugs right by
hermetically sealing the hot apple cider
giving it a shelf life of approximately
a year the jugs then head into a tunnel
where sprayers douse them with cold
water
[Music]
next machinery pulls the liner off of
adhesive-backed labels an electric guy
detects the approaching jugs queuing
rollers to apply the labels
the filtered out pumice from earlier is
cooked four to five hours
this caramelized is the sugars in the
apples turn the pumice into a highly
concentrated spread known as apple
butter they bottle it while it's piping
hot to preserve it although not
technically butter this fruit spread has
a similar consistency it takes a full
day of processing to produce both apple
butter and apple cider it's time to
raise a glass and enjoy the sweet bounty
of the harvest
[Music]